[Music]
we will now meet ABC's Shark Tank star
Kevin oir chairman of oir Ventures and
beant stocks Kevin welcome to the show
thank you very much so we're going to be
talking about nest eggs and it's so
crazy a statistic that I found according
to a Lending Club report more than 60%
of Americans live paycheck to paycheck
and this was as of September of
2023 so how can we create a net steg if
we are living paycheck to paycheck well
first of all that is a a staggering stat
it's actually 62% there's a bunch of
people who measure this and it's very
scary but here's the problem the average
salary in America theay depending on
what region what geography you're in is
around 58 to
$64,000 so the only way you can build a
nest EG is when you start your career
when you start working you have to save
somewhere between 15 and 20% of your pay
check every single pay cycle every two
weeks now it may sound easy but it's not
but if you do that and you just invested
in the US Stock Market S&P 500 you'll
end up with about a million5 in the bank
by the time you turn 65 I know we all
would love to retire as a millionaire
and you mentioned that we should
actually start putting away 15 to 20% of
our paycheck as soon as we start working
so can you please elaborate on how do we
actually do that especially if we are
just starting to work and we're living
paycheck to paycheck well here's the
first task you have to do and it's very
simple and most people don't realize
this you take two sheets of paper you
don't need a computer you don't need
your phone this is as easy as it gets
and you look over a 90-day period 3
months because that really shows your
spending habits no matter where you are
I don't care if you're Manhattan or
you're in San Diego over three months
the way you live will really show itself
so you on the left side you put every
source of income a side hustle a side
job gifts from your grandmother whatever
it is whatever income you have that's on
the left piece of paper how much do you
make over 90 days and on the right side
every cent you spend every cent and you
can get that from your receipts remember
you're doing this for your life you want
to make sure this works you've got to
make sure this is Task number one that
what you bring
in and what you take out are at least
matching you cannot take out more than
you bring in otherwise that is going on
to credit card debt which is now at 20
22 a half% because of Fed rate hikes
nobody can pay off 22 and a half% that's
why I invest in credit card companies
should never let me make money off you
that's exactly what happens so that's
step one and you'd be amazed even very
wealthy people that I show how to do
this outspend themselves they lose money
every single month so that's number one
now here's where it gets a little tricky
you have to modify your behavior so that
now you're saving 15% and that's going
into some kind of a vehicle that's going
to invest it for you every month every
week every day every year it's a
behavioral mindset you have to have if
you want to survive
retirement Yeah you mentioned behavior
and mindset and there's no doubt our
ideas around money definitely have to do
with our mindset but what do we do if
we're going through a lifechanging event
let's say divorce life will throw you
curveballs you will have children you
will have you want to get a mortgage all
of these things I totally get it but if
you put yourself in a mindset that
you're investing in yourself because
that's really what you're doing here
you're not giving this money to anybody
else this is your money and I don't care
if you get married I've I've told every
woman I know in fact one of my Shark
Tank companies is called hello prenup
and we make prenups online for women
because everybody should have a prenup
going into marriage you must keep your
own personal financial identity for your
whole life you don't know with certainty
what life's going to drill you out would
into you don't know what's going to
happen to and so you have to have your
own identity online which means your own
credit score now let's talk about that
for a minute because there's a good way
there's a good hack for that people talk
about debit cards and credit cards let
me explain why when you get out of
college now this is tricky because a lot
of people abuse their credit cards and
they buy too much junk
but the reason you want to get one early
on is so that you can put a $100 on it
each month and pay it off because the
algorithms that determine your personal
credit score don't care about the amount
of credit you pay off it's the fact that
you pay it off in the first place so
over time if you put $50 $20 $100 and
you pay it off every month the AI says
wait a second this person is credit
responsible and I'm going to raise their
credit score up and the reason you want
that is one day you may want a car
loaner one day you may want a mortgage
and the first thing they're going to do
is go to your credit score now another
hack the number one expense you have
when you get out of college or you get
out of high school and you start working
is your
rent this is number one particularly in
places where you are like New York it's
not uncommon to see $1,800 to $2500 for
even a tiny little condo somewhere and
you're renting it that's your number one
expense so how do you manage that and
make it work for you remember you're
going to pay the rent anyways right you
know that with certainty if you buy
nothing else you're going to pay your
rent you're going to be out in the
street so how can I take that let's call
it $2,000 rent and turn it into a
massively High credit score now this
again is one of my companies but I I
this is I got this for my kids let me
show it to you simple credit card called
belt all right here's how it works every
landlord in America will take their
payment on the built card because they
don't get paid any fees giant companies
partnered with this guys with these guys
at buil like Blackstone which have
hundreds of thousands of apartments
across America my kids are on this too
you pay your rent on your bill card and
you pay your bill card off because
you're going to pay rent anyways and
your credit score goes through the moon
and for every dollar of rent you get
points just like you do on any other
credit card so if you pay nothing else
on credit cards you end up with
thousands of points can go on holidays
buy things with it that's genius Kevin
it's fascinating to hear about your
approach to financial literacy for young
adults what are some other Financial
life hacks to transition smoothly from
battling debt to successfully building
their very own nest egg so this is the
key now when you get that discipline you
get that paycheck and you take let's say
15% your goal you have to have some
platform to put it into and over you
know hundreds of years the stock market
has delivered it goes up and down
there's lots of volatility but you're
you're in this for the long game till
you're 65 you get anywhere from 7 to 9%
returns a year but you have to put it
somewhere to do that now there's lots of
apps online the one that I'm involved in
is called Bean stocks you can downloaded
B an STX and the reason it's become so
popular is it also allows you to buy T
bills treasury bills because now rates
have gone up so much that you're getting
anywhere from 4.8 to 5.2% on treasury
bills which theoretically are risk-free
so you can balance your portfolio have
some stocks and have some treasury bills
and basically build over time that Nest
EG and so what it does is average cost
weits you in it's got an index of the
S&P 500 in there and it's got an index
of the treasury bills and you put in 400
200 whatever it is you can afford and
you forget about it it's there on your
phone you can watch every day your
assets grow and you can see the
volatility of the stock market you learn
a lot about it but basically over time
this is the way you create something for
yourself no one this is for no one else
it's for you it's you personally even if
you're married even if you're divorced
it's yours personally my mother taught
me that you know in those days she
taught me in the late you know early 60s
that she took 20% of her salary she was
a working woman and she built a mass of
Nest DEC Nest dec of of treasury bills
and Telco bonds and stock that paid
dividends and she never disclosed it to
both of her husbands she was married
twice and when she passed away they
called me down to the notary's office
and said listen your woman your your
your mother died a very wealthy woman
you've got to come down here you're the
elder brother I said impossible we're
middle class family I know exactly what
she did and she said they said no no no
no you got to get down I called my
brother Shane and said you can't believe
this Shane you can't believe what mom
left behind because she never spent the
principal only the interest I always
wondered how she put me through college
how she helped her brothers and sisters
she was smart that way she wanted
Financial
Independence she didn't want anybody to
be didn't want to be beholden to anybody
when it came to money and she died very
wealthy just using the strategy I'm
talking about now boy did that Chang my
mind about investing I use her as my
adviser she's up in heaven now but she
still knows what she's doing then I love
that she's your Mentor your mom's your
mentor and she actually inspired you to
do exactly what you're doing
today so lastly I want to talk about the
tax advantages and incentives that are
available for individuals building a
nest egg there are plenty of programs
that you can use that allow you to acrw
interest and capital gains on a tax
advantage basis and you you can learn a
lot about this online or go to beant
stocks and look at it as well but the
whole idea is the government is wants
you that want you to be a saver because
they're scared as everybody else is that
if we only depend on Social Security
that's not enough to live on when you're
65 and so by giving you the incentive to
Bear all this interest and all this all
these capital gains tax-free yes they'll
tax you when you start paying it out to
yourself but that's decades from now an
IRA a 401k all of these programs that
you can use to do this and you should
take advantage of them to to the max but
it's the same theme you've got to save
you have to save now we should talk
about how you adjust the way you live
and I'm going to give you an example and
everybody's guilty of it I was guilty of
it for years go into your closet and
look at all the crap you bought that you
don't wear look at all that crap you
have
to up to 70% of what's in your closet
you never wear you bought it cuz you
thought you wanted it it you never wear
it and this is what you've got to learn
another lesson from my mother she would
save all year to buy one Chanel jacket
cuz that's she just loves Chanel and she
would buy really high quality you know
the chenel jackets the Vintage jackets
and I didn't realize how much women
coveted that after she passed away all
the women in the family it was a cat
fight for her Chanel suits and I thought
this is crazy these some of these suits
were bought in the mid6 but they were
vintage Chanel same with her Handbags
and so I realized how smart that was she
didn't have a lot of stuff she just had
really good stuff and that lasted her
whole life the same idea is what I've
adopted you see this Shark Tank outfit
this suit it's the same suit you've
never seen me any any different I got 25
of these 25 shirts 25 ties 25 red poofs
it's a uniform for me I don't have to
think about what I'm going to wear this
is it
and I think that's brilliant I stole
that one from Steve Jobs he' wear the
same black pants and turtleneck every
time I used to work for them back at
Apple in the old days it's brilliant
there's so many hacks you can do and I
have five pairs of shoes they're all
prattas they're beautiful shoes but I
don't need any more than that two red
belts two black belts you go into my
closet they're beautifully hung up no
waste I don't have 15,000 pairs of
sneakers you don't need all that crap
you've got to get disciplined
thank you Kevin so much you gave us a
lot to think about and it was so
interesting I especially love all the
financial hacks the ones that the kids
should be doing as soon as they're going
off to college I know so important Kevin
thank you so much for coming on wake up
absolutely Take Care thank you so much